too many people Bruce Lee represents the
absolute peak in human physical
performance and athleticism he was
renowned for his incredibly low body fat
which gave him this wicked looking for
Zeke but what was much more impressive
than the way his physique that looked
was what it could do Bruce Lee was
capable of some incredible feats of
power and he may well have been one of
the strongest people alive
pound for pound during his lifetime so
let's take a look at the way Bruce Lee
trains if we can learn something from
his notes and see if perhaps we can
apply some of the principles he used to
our own training methods
the first thing that makes Bruce Lee
unique among his contemporaries was the
fact that he trained with weights at all
at the time most martial artists believe
that if they train with weights it would
make their muscles big and bulky and
slow and this would make them less
effective as fighters Bruce Lee did the
research however and he knew that he
could use martial arts training in
combination with bodybuilding and
powerlifting type techniques in order to
develop more explosive power through
that fast twitch muscle fiber and that
mind-muscle connection and that's what
his training was all about he wasn't
really interested in building size he
was much more mature than building pure
power
so he used some quite unique training
methods that are slightly different from
what you might be familiar with as a
bodybuilder perhaps or just as a regular
gym rat but allowed him to build this
kind of insane strength without packing
on that much exercise recently only
weighed about 135 pounds so it's quite a
small guy but the stuff you could do
with that such as the one the two finger
push-up such as apparently holding
barbells out at arm's length for long
periods of time weighing 40 kilograms
they demonstrate that he had a awful lot
of power behind him the first thing that
really sets Bruce Lee apart is his
philosophy and the emphasis he put on
philosophy in his training I've written
recently about the importance of a
training philosophy and Bruce Lee
epitomizes this idea Bruce Lee didn't
just train because he wanted to look
good Bruce Lee trained because he wanted
to be a better fighter and beyond that
he believed the martial arts were the
perfect way to express yourself he
wanted to have the ability to be in full
complete control of his body so that
when he wanted to do something it was
right there so that he could be
completely in sync with his emotions he
used to say when he wants to punch you
better believe he's gonna punch it so he
had to develop that speed and that power
and this is the driving force behind
what he did this is why he was so
committed to training it's why he truly
believed in it and that's why he was
willing to put in so much work he wasn't
training for a goal just training for
the love of training he was like a
real-life Goku or something always
coming up with new ways to push the
envelope and that's the other thing
about Bruce Lee he didn't just settle
for following a training program highly
personal trainer as your I might instead
he was constantly experimenting with
brand new techniques of pushing the
envelope
developed jeet kune do-- believing that
he should do away with a classical mess
of martial arts he also didn't just
follow conventional bodybuilding wisdom
he did the research he looked into the
studies and he tested on himself in that
way he's very much like one of the
earliest biohackers he was constantly
experimenting with new ways to not just
gain incremental increases in strength
but to push the envelope and to actually
exponentially unlock entirely different
kinds of power and you're going to see
some of the ways he did that in a second
so in terms of just a general training
program Bruce Lee would do a fairly
regular combination of compound
movements isolation movements and CV he
did a lot of functional training so that
means deadlifts and squats and clean and
presses because he believed that would
give him more power you see pictures of
him doing one-armed presses using the
muscles in unison in order to make them
more useful but he did also do isolation
training there's lots of images and
videos of him doing bicep curls and I
heard somewhere someone said if you
think bicep curls aren't functional then
you've obviously never wrestled and
clearly bruce lee agreed with that idea
on top of all that weight lifting bruce
lee was also do a lot of cv apparently
he would run nearly every single day
when he could and he was constantly
adding progressive overload by running
faster doing tempo runs trying to pushes
anaerobic threshold or even running with
resistance running with weight strapped
to his back to make it more difficult on
top of this he also did early interval
training which wasn't really a thing at
the time he did this in the same way
that you might structure a boxing round
so he'd do two minutes of intense
training and then one minute rest which
would be the rest between rounds and
then you go again bruce lee like i said
was something of a pioneer something of
a davinci of the body constantly
discovering things ahead of his time
interval training being one of them now
many people recommend interval training
but like I said he's also partial to a
lot of CV and steady-state CV and the
reason for this is that he believed it
was better for his overall ability to
continue to output energy for long
periods of time and he explained that if
you're going to be a fighter you really
need this ability it's no good to get a
punch and kick hard if you can be out of
breath after the third kick and then you
have to lie down he said something along
the lines of if you don't have a good
cardiovascular system then you need to
look into a more peace
full activity as your hobby for that
interval training Bruce Lee would be
using punches and kicks and jabs against
the heavy bag which makes sense as a
martial artist and he would also train
each of his different strikes on
different days splitting them like a
bodybuilder might split body parts to do
kicks on one day's punches on another
day etc so when you combine all that
running the lifting the striking you
realize Bruce Lee was just completely
dedicated to his training and it's no
wonder that you had this incredibly low
body fat and just looked like something
out of a comic book because you know if
you're going to train for those kinds of
hours then that's how you go end up
looking and like I said Bruce Lee used
some more interesting training methods
as well he didn't just do lifting when
he was doing his weight training he
thought that bit outside the box again
and this is where he came up with some
really unique and interesting ideas one
of them being speed training so on these
days Bruce Lee would try and increase
the challenge of his workouts but he
wouldn't do it the way most of us do it
by increasing the weight or by
increasing the number of repetitions
instead he'd do it by increasing the
speed at which he completed the workout
so the same workout would try and
compete it faster times a little bit
like something that CrossFitters are
doing these days but the reason this was
interesting to Bruce Lee in particular
is because when you use explosive fast
movements you're essentially engaging
more fast twitch muscle fiber you're
telling the body it needs explosive
force and the body can't tell the
difference between resistance and
acceleration forces force that's what it
needs to generate to get fast that's
what it needs to generate to lift
something heavy
so by lifting the same weights faster as
far as the muscles are concerned it's
the same thing as lifting them heavier
it'll engage more fast twitch muscle
fiber but it probably won't result in
quite the same muscle damage and
micro-tears meaning that he could
potentially develop more strength
without creating quite so much
hypertrophy apart from anything else
this is just a great way to mix things
up and I recommend trying it and you'll
see right away that it definitely
challenges you in a slightly different
way to what you're perhaps used to so
why not give that a go another thing
Bruce Lee did that was quite different
whether you use a lot of isometric
training isometric of course means that
you're holding it's the opposite of
plyometric instead of explosive movement
you're holding one position so for
instance you might hold the bicep you
might hold the bicep curl position using
dumbbells and then slowly allow them
drop as you completely use up all of
your strength
recently believe that because you're
holding it in the point where there's
the most resistance to it's the most
difficult as opposed to having the arm
straight or up here you're engaging the
most strength however at the same time
you're not going to the full range of
motion
they bruce lee you use combine this kind
of training with regular training why
just describe there where you're holding
the weight and letting it gradually fall
that's called yielding isometrics that's
where you're holding the weight and then
letting yourself fatigue but that's not
the only type of it's from our isometric
training bruce lee used and it's also
probably not the most interesting the
most interesting kind of isometrics that
bruce lee would use was called
overcoming isometrics and here what he
would do is he'd hold on to a really
heavy weight that he literally couldn't
lift so for instance he'd lie under a
bench press and he'd load up the bar to
be 200 kilograms or 300 who knows
obviously can lift and then he would
just strain to try and push it he did
the same thing with squatting he'd have
a squat rack where the bar was on his
neck but it was locked in place so we
just try and push up this bar that
wasn't going anywhere
likewise you do the same with curling by
chaining a bar to the ground and then
trying to curl it obviously he could not
you hold that position for a few seconds
let it go and try again this is the
definition of what happens when an
unstoppable force meets an immovable
object bruce lee being that unstoppable
force i've actually talked about this
kind of overcoming isometrics in the
past and again what makes it interesting
is its ability to recruit those faster
twitch muscle fibers when you're pushing
against something that won't move or
pulling against something that won't
move again your brain and your muscle
fibers they don't know the difference
between something that's locked in place
and something that's just really heavy
so to begin with you're just pulling and
pushing as hard as you can and you're
recruiting all of the vast mass twitch
muscle fibers so you're training your
ability to exert maximum strength at a
given time not only could this
potentially strengthen those fast twitch
fibers but more importantly you can
strengthen the mind muscle connection
the mind muscle connection is a concept
in bodybuilding that describes obviously
the connection between the mind and the
muscle
phoo from the brain through down the
nervous system through the neuromuscular
Junction and then to the muscle itself
when you tell yourself to move you send
the signal it travels there and then you
recruit a certain amount of muscle when
you need to different people have
differing levels of muscle fiber
recruitment and it tends to be anywhere
between thirty and fifty percent fifty
percent being highly trained athlete so
even a highly trained definitely can't
call upon all of their muscle fibers at
once because if they did they could
cause injury to their tendons and
ligaments and they could likewise
completely fatigue themselves which in
the wild would leave you completely
vulnerable to predators Dennis Rogers is
a guy who can naturally by genetics call
upon more muscle fiber it's been shown
in studies and this gives him
fantastic strength for his sizes small
guy but he may be currently one of the
strongest men pound-for-pound look him
up online ingest some incredible things
so bruce lee was potentially training
this kind of recruitment by doing
overcoming isometrics by trying to
encourage his body to recruit as much
muscle fiber as possible it's just the
simple said principle specific
adaptations to impose demands if you
call upon your fast twitch muscle fiber
you will learn to be better at calling
upon your fast twitch muscle fiber
recently also training this mind muscle
connection another way using something
called ice attention that just means
contracting the entire body following a
workout he would then stand up and
contract the entire body this is very
similar to bodybuilders who might pull a
pose straight after doing a set of curls
except for the difference being he
wasn't just doing the bicep pose he'd be
doing an entire body
most muscular kind of engaging the
entire musculature by doing this he
gained made sure that he was constantly
thinking about the role of all of his
muscles in any movement and if he tried
doing something like a press up or pull
up and he tense your entire body you'll
find it makes you much more rigid and
this actually makes you better at
performing those movements this might be
how lucy was able to do is incredible
two finger push-up if you think about it
when you're locked in place like this
you're rigid as opposed to letting your
kind of waist sag and your arms and legs
sag and that means that there's it's
much easier to move this rigid baton
than it is
move something's wobbling around at the
same time loosely with ten tolas muscles
during the workout so whilst doing the
curls he did tensing the rest of his
body he believed that control came from
tension and this makes a lot of sense
when you're doing an isolation movement
because if you tense the rest of your
body it essentially removes any momentum
and any possibility that you might be
helping the target muscle to actually
improve the isolation allows you to
train it much harder on top of all this
Bruce Lee also was a firm believer in
training abs and in training for arms he
trained his forearms of this grip every
single day and he trained his abs every
single day he believes that the forearms
and the grip was one of the keys to
strength and this is something that he
shared with classic bodybuilders he
trained his forearms because he knew
that strength in your hands gives you
strength throughout your entire body if
you've got a firmer grip on something
you can lift more and of course in
martial arts it's very important and yes
he trained its core every single day as
well because that's where you generate
all your power in a martial arts strike
if you're punching someone that punch
doesn't just come from your arm and your
shoulder it comes from your entire waist
the torque that you can generate your
Bleek's your legs your pushing through
the ground like so so it's crucial to
build the core and the core is also
what's involved in everything else we
were talking about tensing the whole
body so that you could do two finger
push-ups more easily and again that
comes from having a strong sturdy core
so bruce lee would trade his core every
single day and of course is very famous
for that exercise called the dragon flag
where he would lie with his upper
shoulders touching the bench but not the
rest of his body and he would lower his
legs and raise them again he was one for
quite dynamic and impressive looking
exercises so there you go hope found
this interesting and useful that's how
Bruce Lee trained as you could see he
took a very different approach to most
people and he really was something of an
innovator or a pioneer when it came to
exercising he was ahead of his time with
many of the concepts he used but a lot
of them still aren't in YG's today so
try incorporating some of these ideas
into your training if you're interested
in performance overlooks if you're
interested in learning to use your
muscle as well as just show it so thanks
very much for watching guys if you have
liked this video please consider liking
sharing and subscribing a bit spin
useful I might be returning to the
subject of Bruce Lee in feature because
there's a lot more we haven't touched on
am I going to his philosophy in a bit
more depth for instance let me know in
the comments if that's something you'd
like to see and of course I'll be having
many more videos coming soon on topics
ranging from fitness to strength to
running to brain training to
productivity to working online all the
usual stuff
so stay tuned and bye for now